the sentencing phase just wrapping up
for the day for the box truck driver who
killed five cyclists in september rather
december near searchlight
45 year old jordan barson admitted he
was under the influence of meth when he
ran into that group on u.s 95.
joe muller in the courtroom today where
relatives and victims
shared their struggles moving on or
trying to without their loved ones
brian it was an emotional day in court
we heard from some of the family members
of those victims and we also heard from
the accused jordan barson
now back in april barson entered a plea
agreement which would reduce
the charges he was facing to two counts
of dui resulting in death
family of some of the victims described
how the sudden deaths of their loved
ones change their lives
the first family member to speak was
donna trauger the wife of tom trauger
she shared how the loss of her husband
haunts her every day
i wasn't prepared when i drove out to
the crash site and saw the letters
hd and ft sprayed on the road
and later learned that these were used
to identify where the head and feet of
the victims lay dead
these words and images haunt me as i lie
in bed at night waiting
praying hoping for sleep to come
at the start of the sentencing hearing
barshen stood up via video and said he
was
sorry and that he is ashamed with
himself he says after he gets out of
prison he wants to share his story and
rehab facilities to prevent another
tragedy
like this now barson faces up to 40
years in prison we
expect to hear from more family members
of those victims tomorrow and sentencing
continues
reporting live in downtown las vegas joe
mohler 8 news now